what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
wall street's trying to get rich for us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
planet evilova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p she's got a profile shirt on
let's go don't forget that lunch money
is now sponsored by
block five go get a block by account
blockfy.com
pomp you can buy crypto you can earn up
to eight point six percent apy in an
interest bearing account
or you can get some cash without having
to sell your crypto they'll give you a
us dollar loan to get your crypto
collateral go to blockby.com
an investor i'm a happy user and if you
get an account
you will be happy as well
what's up what's up what's up there is a
nor'easter
thing coming whatever that is and it
blew my hair
over the pre-wind blew it all over
supposed to be here until
thursday so i don't know how it's
tomorrow wednesday i ain't gonna be here
i'm leaving how is it blowing your hair
the pre-wind let's go pre-wind
so so did mine come on goldman sachs ceo
david solomon told cnbc on tuesday that
small businesses it surveyed
are in dire need of another round of
emergency paycheck protection program
funding or ppp he said they really have
needs 90
of them have exhausted their ppp funding
at this point
more than half of them have had to lay
off employees and really constrain their
businesses
wild idea wild idea you want to know
what will solve the problem
open up the businesses the vaccine is
here
they were bringing it down the tunnel i
saw a meme it had the espn
nba music plan it is here
there was another place they brought the
vaccine they were doing an unboxing
video
like they were on youtube they're like
and now for the big moment
they took it out and they put it in a
refrigerator that had two doors
well the vaccines here somebody already
took the vaccine a new york city nurse
google is delaying employees return to
offices to september 1st
and will expect employees to report to
work in person for at least
three days a week thereafter but
uh in an email sent to the people uh
google ceo said that he expects workers
to live within commuting distance of
offices so you can't just pack your bags
and move if you work for google
wrong answer wrong answer the angle make
people come in the office watch
he said with new vaccines on the horizon
thanks to the incredible ingenuity of
our medical and scientific community a
return to normal
is now in sight
wrong answer the angle make people go to
the office they're saying they will
ain't nobody going to the office watch
speaking of somebody not going to the
office oracle
is moving to texas oracle ceo
larry ellison said he has moved his
primary residence
to hawaii becoming the latest silicon
valley executive to depart the state
where they built their fortunes do you
want to know why everyone's leaving
california
because they got stupid politicians who
ruined
those economies remember in l.a
when they banned walking outside but
they put in don't be hitting me i'm
gonna say my peace
they banned walking outside but they put
carve outs in case you want to play golf
or pickleball
that's how stupid these people are it's
nothing else other than
stupidity it has nothing to do with the
virus i've heard this piece it's got
everything to do with control
i saw a tweet you know what the tweet
said we went from stop touching your
face and just wear a mask
to literally you're gonna take a vaccine
that's how quick they take your rights
and let them try to mandate it you want
to see riots
let them try to mandate the people that
they have to take
this turned into a very political lunch
money i apologize that was not my intent
it's just be honest it's just nonsense
do you think it's not nonsense
rihanna's lingerie brand savage
by fenty is reportedly seeking to raise
a hundred million
dollars in funding in order to expand
into athletic wear
savage by fenty is a fire i think she's
if i'm not
wrong i think she's the highest paid
she's like one of the highest paid music
i don't know after that
i just like the name so so the company
has hired goldman sachs to raise the new
round of funding which may be used to
expand in europe and launch the
new line of athletic clothing rihanna is
a very savvy business woman for those
who think that she's just an artist
she is a business savage how do you know
because i know watch this one billion
dollar evaluation is what they think
uh savage by fenty may get
so rihanna tops forbes list of
wealthiest female musicians with
eye-popping 600 million
how much beyonce got i don't think she's
got that much i don't think i don't
think this makes sense
let's see yeah okay let's see i don't
know just do
beyonce net worth that's we gotta google
beyonce now yeah but i think that that
did you guys ever think you would
tune into a youtube show for live
googling 400 million
uh rihanna 600 million
i mean if those numbers are true then
yeah that would be true
yeah 600. all right
rihanna shout out to you savage by fenty
i love it
savage my thing all right all right it's
lingerie
oh is it really damn even better savage
by fenty
i'm in trouble you're in trouble look go
ahead so
apple launched its fitness plus
yesterday to compete with
peloton's offering i am on the
one month free something's in my mouth
i am on the one month free trial and
i looked at it it's a very very basic
introductory um workouts i
don't exactly think it's going to
compete with peloton
in the way that it thinks it well i
didn't realize you were a professional
athlete
and you were so bored no it's like
literally like six exercises and
it's like okay you're done it's just
like oh i can do better than that
but there's not only six exercises no no
in like one video
the same ones it's just i mean you were
not impressed
i was not impressed and i don't think
hardcore uh because if you look at
peloton there's some hardcore people
that do those workouts it's not like
you know graham off the street is doing
these little
dumb bell things so i mean i'm not sure
i'm more i'm more of a food fitness
enthusiast
i think you would enjoy apple fitness
plus food fitness what up
okay y'all don't even know what that is
a volcano eat as much food as possible
in one sitting
food fitness a volcano in italy
erupted on sat sunday evening in an
explosion that sent streams of fiery
lava
fountaining down the mountain slope
nobody was hurt
nobody died and even there's a airport
nearby
that kept taking off it didn't even
affect it i don't be messing with it
volcanoes
it's crazy uh it's one of the world's
most active
volcanoes in 2017 when it was a violent
explosion and uh when its
magma touched the snow it created high
pressure pockets of steam and
ten people were injured now i don't be
messing with volcanoes to start with
then i'll be messing with them when they
erupted i definitely don't be messing
with them but they erupt a lot we went
to iceland
and we did a lava tunnel tour that was a
volcano
you didn't mind that that was an old one
that was a calm one they chilled out
that's what i'm into the chill ones like
cool you want to chill out fine i don't
need to go in the volcano we were in the
volcano no we were in the lava tunnel
that's where the lava flows over and
down into it
it's a difference i was i was walking
where it had been not where it's going
to be
do you remember the magic school bus um
volcano or
going into the earth no i don't go and i
don't go in the earth i don't mess with
volcanoes i don't mess with any of that
stuff you know why
no it's like the ocean respect the sea
that's what you're supposed to do you're
supposed to respect the ocean
and you're supposed to respect earth
don't be playing with it don't be trying
to outsmart it
the earth will win and the ocean will
win all these people want to be going
swimming across the ocean and [ __ ] and
then they wonder why that guy died i
don't know you try to swim across the
ocean
are you scared of sharks and i are cool
i don't mess with them they don't mess
with me if they try to mess with me we
would have a problem but we don't have
any problems
ready for ask lunch money time guys if
you have a question by the way the
sharks are talking [ __ ] right now i can
hear them
they're like oh that dude thinks that we
ain't gonna mess with him watch this i
ain't going in the ocean
i only go up to like my my wishes they
can get you there
yeah cool at least they come back and
punch them and stuff like
you know you get coming down get a
little throw your shoulder into it
that's by the way that's the by the way
that's how you beat up a shark is you
punch it in the nose for those that
don't know when it's
thrashing around how are you gonna know
where its nose is
please i am lightning fast my hands are
so quick
the shark will be like damn i think i
just got hit three times
shark won't even know what hit it it'll
bite your hand off so fast and your
shoulder
nah i'll knock its teeth out a little
less scaly looking teeth go ahead come
on why you got me talking [ __ ] to a
shark now
how did i start talking [ __ ] to a
hypothetical shark
[ __ ] volcanoes and sharks oh i thought
kid show sorry what is going on today
well if you're gonna say tell me your
shark gonna eat me then i'm gonna tell
you i'm gonna eat the shark
by the way more humans eat sharks than
sharks humans we're
done what's the questions for ask lunch
money please put your questions below
with
ask lm also guys a lot of scammers
impersonating anthony in the comments
please do not send them money please do
not respond just report yeah i don't
need your money
okay nashee
i think what's your take on the value of
gold in the coming years as bitcoin
continues to rise
do you think gold will become obsolete
or will it coexist with bitcoin is
another
investment option well i personally
think that
bitcoin and gold can co is coexist in
peace i don't think one will overtake
the other
i just think that a lot of people have
been taking their money from gold and
investing it in bitcoin so there you go
well if they do that then one will
overtake the other
so you're you're right in that people
are going to take their money out of
gold and put it back
i think that gold market cap is going to
be smaller than bitcoin's market cap
with by the end of 2020s
not 2020 but the 2020s just before
anybody gets crazy
so december 31st 2029
i think that bitcoin's market cap will
be bigger than gold's
next meet busy hey
damn it's meat to the busy get it
because a to the anthony
12th p to the olena okay well you didn't
say what up yinz
i've been on the internet i know people
everywhere in pennsylvania
i know i've heard this question but
never got a good answer
if more than 51 of btc hash power is in
china what stops the chinese government
from taking them over
or forcing their hands china's just
going to shut them down china can't take
control of them
so they're just going to uh shut them
down if they try they can try to take
the electricity away
or whatever control of them what do you
mean
you just said they can't take control
why not yeah well because the control
of all of them like china isn't going to
nationalize the mining
instead of what they've done in the past
if they try to put regulation they try
to take away electricity
like everything they've done in the past
has been about
uh shutting down the miners uh not
trying to control them i don't think
that they're gonna control them
why not i'm not having this debate
people are dumb people asking these
questions if you're genuinely interested
you've never heard the answer before
i appreciate the question people who are
trolling
shut up wait i don't get it of course
you don't
it's all right it's like a bitcoin weird
thing it ain't happening
stop worrying about it all right don't
worry about china i guess
what's next that's it do you have any
other sayings for the people
no no i appreciate the people are you
ready are you ready for
uh me to beat up a shark no
all right guys this got sober real fast
i don't know what happened see you guys
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends